let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 why don't we go to our caller
from country code 52 this could be an
interesting one country code 52 what's
your name where are you calling from
country code 52 or 524 yellow hello
hello there hi David okay can you hear
me yes who's this
oh I don't know if you remember me and
the guys that call from Mexico City a
couple of months ago what was your name
- PLO sans yeah okay very good
yeah you might be calling in from a
different number because we didn't have
you in the caller ID Oh beg your pardon
yes I just want to make a quick question
because I'm in a college break and I was
reading about what's been happening in
Ecuador with protests regarding learning
more in his presidency and I'm
especially terrified that I there's a
probability for presidency with Rafael
Correa which try to perpetuate himself
in power and honestly I have some
relatives in Ecuador and I would I would
just like I would like to know what do
you think of the situation how do you
think is gonna and I have no idea how
it's going to end I've been reading up
on it in both American media but also in
Latin American media and I if you said
you've you've got a bet gun to my head I
have to bet what happens there I truly
have no idea these situations are like a
tinderbox they're extraordinarily
unpredictable and if I were you I would
be I don't have family in Ecuador but I
would be extraordinarily worried about
what's going on for sure what do you
think is going the most likely outcome
ah well if I'm not mistaken Rafael
Correa is prohibited to go and run for
election because he's being investigated
by corruption if I don't mistake
yes but he had support of the indigenous
people which are the ones that are
revolting
so actually lady marina was the vice
president of her friend Cory so maybe
you could have some kind of a crisis
there in which he could go or or have
some kind of puppet go to that puppet
over there yeah and if Anna it's it's
pretty bad because I also read that he
was hiding it in Venezuela with Maduro
and you know that does not give me good
books about the situation you know that
should not make anybody please yeah so
listen we'll be following it and I I
don't know what's going to happen but it
I actually have a I'm worried including
I mean what's going on in Argentina also
is very bad Christina may be coming back
which is very very scary it could become
a very dark decade yeah in Latin South
America actually yes we have for Sona
right in Brazil yeah we have or thin
Nicaragua not getting out of power
I'm optimistic with Amador in Mexico but
there are a lot of people especially
what was was what has been happening but
there's a print court lately that with
some corruption scandals I don't know
what the thing honestly but I'll try to
be yeah and actually I mean Mex Mexico
is one of the places that seems to be
going in a less negative direction
lately
in Central and South America yeah to
some extent to some extent
I'm studying college in Mexico City very
nice i panel I've never yet but I plan
to go very very soon yeah I remember you
said it on a video are you going to go
to some kind of Cancun trip or to some
somewhere near there no no I plan to go
to or to the city to the capital soon oh
great yeah be awesome if you were to
come here and as your our beautiful
country our Mexico I enjoyed and I love
Mexico love the people of the culture
love the art love
the food I mean it's just fantastic
Thanks thank you very much man
I really appreciate it and that just a
final question I'm so sorry I almost got
ago you had a an ad with a battle in
which you were saying that you learned
Italian and you were learning German I'm
eager to learn a third language but I
don't know what should third language do
you Rick do you recommend me to learn I
would recommend Hebrew it's so useful so
many people speak it Hebrew I'm kidding
I really it's cool it's cool cuz it's a
different alphabet but no I mean I would
if I were you I would learn what what do
I have no idea I learned French as my
third language and I love it
French is also nice yeah that would be
cool yeah I'm also you get a to learn
Latin and in college that's pretty hard
I wouldn't do that that sounds fun thing
alright Santiago I got a run I
appreciate the phone call I hope to hear
from you again